>> So, thanks for coming out.
I'm super excited to
host today as Smita and
David who are visiting
from Colombia.
>> Yale.
>> Yale, sorry. Look at
us. I was jumping ahead.
Smita did her postdoc in
Columbia with Donna [inaudible].
So, she's been at Yale
for last three years now.
I was in Columbia before that.
So, I'm off because I
really should stop now.
So, they'll talk a lot
about high dimensional learning
for single cell in particular,
and as she says, Smita came from
Donna's group at
Yale before that.
>> Didn't come [inaudible].
>> I really should
now. Before that,
it was The University of
Michigan or maybe it was
[inaudible] something
I don't know.
David was at a University
in Amsterdam for his PhD,
but he actually spent most
of his time at Weitzmann,
which is right next
door to Israel.
Working with [inaudible] and
is now a postdoc with Smita at
either Columbia or Yale
or one of those two.
[inaudible] Also, there's folks
on Skype too as well, so.
>> Okay.
>> For anyone on
Skype, I will get on.
If you want to ask a question,
type it in and I'll be there.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. I'm going to
go ahead and get started.
If you have any
questions or if you
want to know more
about something,
I guess I agree you
can ask me right
away or you can
ask me at the end,
and then David has
extra slides on it,
everything if you want to go into
more detail about
anything specific.
Now, I'm just going to talk about
basically what our group does.
We're jointly located in
Computer Science and
the Medical School at Yale,
and we're basically
a machine learning
or applied maths type group,
and we develop techniques
that are meant to
analyze complex biomedical data,
and can usually or
often be applied to
other types of data
because we believe
that the bar for analyzing
biomedical data is a little bit
higher because there can
be all kinds of sparsity,
missing information,
very, very noisy,
a lot of nonlinear effects
and things like that,
so we believe that if
basically we do unsupervised
machine learning techniques,
so if we're able to detect
those sorts of patterns and
hopefully we can detect
other sorts of patterns as well.
So, as I was mentioning,
our group develops
techniques that deal
with data that can be
very high dimensional,
so you're measuring a lot
of different features.
Often, we apply our techniques
to single cell and
sequencing data where the
features are transcript counts,
mRNA transcript counts, but
we've applied it on a
variety of other datasets.
Also high throughput, so
there's a lot of different units.
So, we've tended to work
with single cell data
where the units are
cells or data where
the units are patients,
but there's a lot of them.
There's a lot of heterogeneity
within the dataset,
which means that we
want to learn what
the different ways that
the data itself is stratified,
what the different patterns are,
how much information and
redundancy there is
in the features.
The challenges, this kind
of data can pose is,
as I mentioned, there
could be sparsity.
Even though there's
many, many features,
a lot of them could be missing
for a lot of the data points.
There's a lot of noise,
so there could be a very
extrinsic noise background,
ambient noise or there could
be specific types of noise.
There is nonlinearity in
the shape of the data and
how the features
relate to each other,
and just the scale of it can
pose computational problems,
so the algorithms
need to be scalable.
So, with this kind of data,
one question that
we often ask is,
how do we look at this data?
So, how you might have
a lot of data and often you
might not even have
any ideas what
your data can tell you or
what can even predict.
So, in this circumstance,
we have unsupervised techniques
that will help you just look
at and explore the data and even
generate hypotheses from it.
So, some of the technologies
in biology that are
generating this scale of data
is mass cytometry or site
off as he mentioned,
which generates a lot
of protein channels.
RNA sequencing,
hich CTCR sequencing,
which I know a lot
of you work with,
and the list goes on.
This is, we think this thing
just keeps exploding
and there's more and
more technologies
that are capable of
generating this.
So, how do we deal
with these challenges?
What are the themes that
we've seized upon in our lab
is the fact that even though
the data is measured in
a high dimensional space,
it has intrinsically low
dimensional structure.
So, for example, in
the gene sequence,
RNA sequencing world,
there are a lot of
genes that you measure.
These genes have a high degree of
informational redundancy
between them,
and as a result the cell types
and states are constraints.
So, there's an intrinsically
lower dimensional shape here,
so the ambient space
was a lot bigger than
the intrinsic shape,
and so, that's one of the
principles we use in our lab.
How do we learn this lower
dimensional intrinsic shape?
As you can see, this
shape can be non-linear.
How do we understand
the shape and ED?
One of the fields in math that
we use a lot is
graph signal processing,
where there's in this theory
of manifolds and we show
that we can also implement
the same concept
with Deep Learning,
where not only does
the data have shape,
but there is some
smoothness in it.
So, the smoothness or
the locality and
the data can really help
you learn and
understand this shape.
I'll give you an example here,
smoothness meaning your
data points are occupying
the state space in
some semi regular fashion,
even if they're not
uniformly sampled across it,
you have samples in
different parts of
it so that you can learn
something about it.
It doesn't have to
be one smooth shape,
it can be a collection of them.
So basically, if you have
this highly non-linear lower
dimensional structure,
how do you learn it?
The very basic way
you learn it is you
look for very similar data
points to every data point.
To some level of granularity,
even if you have high
dimensions and noise,
you should be able
to tell data points
that are very similar to
your point in a very local way.
So, if you're trying to look
for points that
are very far away,
you can get lost because,
unless you know this is
structured like a Swiss roll,
you might not
understand the points,
and the different arms
are actually far away,
but you can understand
which points
are very close to each other.
So, once you have
points that are very
close to each other,
you can basically
take a walk by taking
small steps to local neighbors,
and this walk will
somehow help you
clarify the shape of
the data and find
this highly nonlinear
intrinsic dimension
that the data follows.
So, when you walk in
small steps you can
define Markov Matrix that says,
starting from any point,
you're going to transition
to other points
based on your measure
of similarity.
That measure of
similarity doesn't
have to be necessarily
very perfect.
It can be pretty rough,
but as you walk longer distances,
the probabilities add up,
so that you hone,
the longer you walk,
the more you hone in on the main
dimensions of the shape.
So, this concept is
called data diffusion
or a random walk
and this data diffusion type
concept where you find
these main non-linear
Eigen dimensions,
turns out to be the basis of
graphs signal processing.
So, we used this concept for
the first project that David
and I did together that was
just published in Cell,
and it's an algorithm
called MAGIC,
and what MAGIC shows
is that by learning
this manifold of the data,
you can restore
values to cells that
were missing or you can
denoise cells such that you
can further process them,
so restoring data basically
to the mean manifold dimensions.
The motivating problem was in
single cell RNA sequencing,
which came out about
three years ago,
you have a salvaging
count matrix,
but most of it is missing,
just by the way
RNA capture works,
it's like reaching into your cell
and grabbing five to
10 percent of the transcripts,
and the rest of them
you leave in the cell.
So, given this, a lot of what
I've done with site off,
for example, in my post-doc,
which is try to learn
relationships and signaling
the relationships
between proteins,
could no longer be done.
So, if you're looking
per gene now,
and you're trying to
get information from
your 20,000 genes as far as
with gene has a relationship
or correlation with another gene,
it becomes very hard
to discern this
because you're not seeing
both the genes in
the same cell at all.
So, if you only see
one gene in 10 percent of
the cells and another gene
in another 10 percent in cells,
the likelihood of you
seeing both genes in
the same cell is one in
one hundred and so a lot of
this data is dropped out,
and you can't do that type
of gene regulatory analysis
that seems to be promised
by the technology.
So, the steps of
MAGIC basically are that you
start with a cell by gene matrix,
you calculate
distances, but again,
you don't trust
faraway distances.
So, you localize the distances by
passing it through
a Gaussian affinity.
So, that gives you
very local neighbors and
then you Markov normalize it
to create a Random-Walk matrix.
Then you exponentiate
this matrix to compute
the probabilities of
longer Random-Walks.
Then, this has honed
in on the main
dimensions of the data.
So, if you, eigen decompose
it then you'd get what's
called a diffusion math,
but we don't actually
eigen decompose it.
You basically project
this operator
onto the data to learn
a weighted average of
manifold intrinsic neighbors
to get the imputed data.
So, you basically
have data before
MAGIC and after several
steps of imputation,
when you project, you get
your restored data after MAGIC.
You can see some of
the other types of
noise in the data besides
missing values are also restored.
What the subsequent steps
of diffusion do are,
it connects the manifold
more and more globally.
So, you get more global
directions, and as you do this,
you take off the low noise
dimensions and you hone in on
the main manifold
dimensions and you see
restored relationships per gene.
It can restore it
to nonlinear values
because you're not imposing
any global constraint on
the shape of the relationship
or what you impute.
>> I have a question.
>> Yeah.
>> What is this?
What point single column?
>> It's a single cell.
>> It's a single cell,
but what's the X-axis and Y?
>> They're two genes.
Two random genes you
can think of it as.
>> So, this is single
start a sequencing,
so you count molecules
for genes in a cell.
So, these are molecule counts,
observed molecules counts.
>> I tried to understand
what's on the X-axis,
how do you determine
the co-ordinate?
>> Oh, it's expression level.
>> Also.
>> So, it's just two features,
so you can think of it.
We had a matrix with
a bunch of missing data
and I'm trying to
learn the relationship
between two columns
of the matrix,
just to see if the two columns
have correlation.
So, if you had people,
I'm trying to figure out if
there's correlation between
their I don't know height
and salary or
something like that.
But I just couldn't do it,
because most of it was missing.
When I restored it,
I can restore the relationship
between these two features.
>> So, I understand
in other words,
basically your have
a sparse matrix.
>> Yeah.
>> When you try to complete
two matrix completion.
>> That's right.
>> But actually, it's
not matrix completion,
it's a harder process.
>> I'll talk about why it's
not the same as
matrix completion.
So matrix completion
assumes that the values you
have in your matrix
are okay and you
just have to compute
missing values,
but that's not the situation.
The situation you see, you
under-sampled everything.
So you have a small set
of samples from
your cell and everything is
under counted to some extent.
>> When you think of the
non-zero errors you can't trust.
>> I see.
>> So, final assessment
could be you actually came
to tell what's a missing value.
>> Exactly.
>> What's that bond express.
>> Yeah, there's
nothing no distinction.
>> Exactly. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> The algorithm doesn't
distinguish like that either.
>> Oh, if something's highly
expressed the chance that it
would easier always
is pretty low, right?
You've got something that's
got thousands of transcripts.
>> Well, usually, if
we see a transcript,
it's pretty trustworthy
unless you have
a mapping problem.
>> Yeah. What I'm saying is that
it's not even random
in the sense that if
something's got lots and lots of
transcripts and you have
a 10 percent chance
of taking each one,
and if you have
a 10 percent chance
of taking a thousand things,
they're alternating at zero
or that they're minuscule.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, yeah.
>> If you have a transcript
that dominates.
>> You'll see it.
>> New cancer cells
that go berserk or.
>> Yeah. You might see
the cell cycle genes are
exactly something like that.
So, then you'r interested.
>> Except for the
interesting, sorry
the interesting genes are lowly
expressed like
transcription factors.
>> Surface markers.
>> Interesting stuff that
is highly expressed.
>> Yeah.
>> Unfortunately, yeah.
>> Actin is highly expressive.
>> Actin yeah, as well as actin.
>> So, yeah, I know
exactly cell surface markers
because then you can use them
to sort and study cells,
those are exactly missing.
>> Yeah. Before your imputation.
Did that help answer
your question?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I'm not assuming
you know what these
relationships look like,
although if you know about
epithelial-mesenchymal
transition.
Breast cancer you know that
this is correct direction of
these relationships
because Snail is
a transcription factor and
Vimentin is a mesenchymal marker.
So, when Snail goes on,
Vimentin goes up and then
E-Cadherin and Vimentin
are markers of epithelial
versus mesenchymal state,
so they're not on
it the same time.
>> By the way, I don't know
if you have a slide of
that. We did try.
>> I have a slide of that.
>> We did try matrix
completion techniques.
>> It doesn't work.
>> Then we failed on
the same date just so you know.
>> So, we always try to
find ways to validate it
computationally and otherwise.
So, here we had a gene of worms
that were developing
for the first,
I think it's 48 hours and
they had bulk sequencing.
But there was a natural
manifold structure
that we knew about.
We artificially dropped this data
out and we re-imputed it
with MAGIC and denoised
it as you can see.
The original relationships
got totally messed up,
most of it sunk down to zero.
Then you re-impute it with
MAGIC and you see that
the original relationship is
restored or even
further clarified.
So, why is this
interesting to us?
Because you can learn a lot
about individual genes now,
you can look at
their pairwise relationships.
Their individual probability
distributions are
re-represented and
you can distinguish
between different
populations and how much
of a particular gene
is represented.
In addition to looking
at individual genes,
the overall data is restored.
So, this is before MAGIC
and afterwards you see
a very clear structure
of this data.
This is again, a data
that's mimicking
the epithelial-mesenchymal
transition
on breast cancer cells.
So, we see different structures
corresponding to
the yellow is
mesenchymal cells that
successfully transition
for example.
So, one thing we can do after
MAGIC that we completely
couldn't is do something called
the archetypal analysis.
So, there's data before
MAGIC and after.
The main idea is to fit a
polytope to the extreme ends of
the data to figure out what's
creating the overall shape.
When we did that, we
were able to identify
extreme end points of their shape
that correspond to
chromatin modification.
So, for example now,
biologist could look at
these intermediate states
that people hadn't really
considered that much
and see that there is
a one programmable chromatin
modification that's going on.
So, a lot of times
people hone in on
the first part of this which are
epithelial cells or the last part
which are mesenchymal cells.
They're not really
sure how these cells
transition through
the intermediate
populations and that's
something that you can
start to get a picture
of after you've restored
all your gene values.
This is comparing MAGIC against
matrix completion and
low-rank approximation methods.
So, you can see that the NNMC
is nuclear norm base
matrix completion,
Candace-based method and it
isn't performs super well here.
Low-rank approximation
actually does somewhat better,
but it's a linear methods,
so it's not completely
denoising in the
non-linear directions.
Then you see MAGIC
resource the data shape
to something that's
identifiable to us.
We measured it against
a lot of other ways,
so if people often
ask us do you need
this sort of complicated
Random-Walk technique,
can you just do this by
imputing with KNN
and you see it's not
nearly as good and if you impute
with just your
k-nearest neighbors.
The global manifold connections
actually do make a difference.
When you're learning the shapes,
and you can't use
individual diffusion
components or
anything like that
to get the same.
So, it can't be just simple
smoothing in your graph,
so the manifold learning
actually makes a difference.
So, after we did this project,
so basically what we did was,
we restored the gene values.
We thought we could do
similar inference because
we've learned the gene cell
graph on external variables,
and we thought this
could really help us.
Because the single-cell
RNA sequencing data
now is not only in
a single condition,
but it can be generated in
multiple conditions and now
people want you to
compare conditions.
So, I have the single-cell data
and I have it with perturbation.
So, what's the real difference?
Measuring the difference
actually pretty hard
because there's all this noise
that occludes the difference.
But also, the measurement effect
itself could be weak or
could be measured weakly.
So, we thought we'd
actually treat
this experimental
variable itself as
a similar signal as we treated
a gene and use the same sort of
graph manifold
denoising technique
on an external variable.
But it's configured
a little bit differently
because we don't know
some things about
the experimental variable.
So, this is a technique
that's in preparation,
so David is supervising
this project and Jay and
Dan are working on it.
The idea is to
smooth an external,
perhaps experimental
label on the data graph
to impute continuity
and infer associations.
So, the idea here is you have
cells from condition
one and condition two.
But you've learned
your graph from
single-cell RNA sequencing data
from the whole data on the genes.
Now, you can interpolate
the labels to
get a continuous variable
that can now give you
some enhanced abilities
to tell the difference
between the two conditions.
So, one thing it can
do is it can improve
your ability to correlate
variables with
the experimental condition.
So, before you had
these discrete labels,
between condition one
and condition two,
there really a significant
difference, can you tell?
Often you can only tell if it's
a monotonic relationship
like in A but
you can't tell
a non-monotonic relationship
like you have in B.
So, after you, we
call these melding,
we've turned it into a verb,
so we're melding variables.
After we MELD the variable,
we infer this light
and dimension that
seems much easier to track,
to see if it correlates with
the experimental condition.
So, you can think of
the MELD dimension as a
continuous experimental variable.
The other thing you can do
is help us identify cell types.
So, if you have condition
A and condition
B and you mix samples from it,
you can see which cell types are
enriched in condition
A versus condition B.
So, some of the math behind it,
they're also using
graph signal processing.
So the idea in
graph signal processing
is you have a graph,
and you're treating
this variable as
a signal on that graph.
What you're actually doing is
you're low-pass
filtering this graph.
So, like before,
when you power the matrix,
what you're actually
doing is you're keeping
the high eigen vectors
of this Markov matrix,
which range from one to zero,
but the properties
of Markov matrices.
So, something is one to zero,
and you raise it to a power,
it goes down unless
it's close to one.
That's the property that
you're using that smoothing
on this graph or smoothing
on the Laplacian.
So, you see that before the
smoothing the signal is noisy,
has all these high
frequency components.
As you smooth more and more,
you hone in on the
low-frequency components.
So, you're smoothing
the external variable
on the main directions
of the graph
assuming that the main
directions of the graph
sort of represent the difference.
>> What is T?
>> T would be how much
you power the matrix,
even though in this setup
we actually don't power it.
We have it as
a convex optimization
that trades smoothing
with reconstruction.
But in magic, we had a T
where you powered it.
>> [inaudible] how
stronger [inaudible]
>> How strong you power,
how much you power or
how much you smooth.
So, for example, if you
have time series data
and you're looking at
the expression of
stocks tend this is
some embryonic stem
cell data you impute
continuity to this and
then you can tell there's
two sub-populations and
one sub-population,
rapidly increases
the expression of
succession which is
a marker for some lineage.
I can't remember
which one right now.
This kind of inferences
that you can make,
maybe even more useful
inference we can make
we're testing it
on this HIPC data.
So, the else part of
the human immuno profiling
project consortium.
So, we get basically
site off forcing.
This is single tie
sequencing data
from these different
infectious diseases.
So, this is
lyme disease analysis.
This is the difference between
a patient's first visit and
a patient's second visit.
So, we MELD the visit label
and what we're
starting this T is,
the right side is colored
by the melded time.
So, the populations that are
enriched as their second visit
or in the lighter colors.
Populations that
are more common in
their first visit are
in the purple color.
So, you see that T cells,
there are certain
kinds of T cells
that are showing up in yellow.
If you zoom in on them you
see that the second visit,
there are certain
regulatory T-cell
populations that are appearing.
Regulatory T cells are
actually quite rare and
it would be hard to pick
this out without MELD
smoothing the coloring
on the label.
There are memory T cells that
are upregulated in visit two.
We can generally see
how these populations
arise and then maybe go away
with the different as
the patients come back.
They're expected to come
back more and more time.
So, we're excited about
using MELD for this.
>> Question. So, here you
have two labels, it's all right.
If I understand correctly.
>> You can have
more than two if you
have time steps
like four or five.
>> But, in this particular cases
have one or zero origin.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, you do the matrix
powering eventually you guess
a little bit is a little bit like
diffusion. There's
an external other source.
>> It's exactly like we did.
>> Okay. So, you have
a soft probability in essence.
>> Yeah, you had
a soft probability that in
some respects you
could interpret as
a likelihood that it was
generated by condition
two versus the [inaudible].
>> Setting the score can
be interpret as something,
for example, these are
two visits in time.
So now, you can say that
we imputed the time.
You measured two time points with
the effects at many time points.
But, it's still the score
how likely is that
shelf came from sample
one or sample two.
>> So, when you generalize
the model condition,
then it will become
another normal.
>> Yeah, it would be a
multidimensional and you can
do the same thing right,
if you encode your condition
with 10 bits you
can MELD all the 10 bits.
>> But, you do have cells from
sample one and sample two.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what you are doing
is hallucinating what
happens in between,
right? You're imputing
what happened.
>> Yeah. You're imputing
what will happen.
>> This simple analysis,
you haven't changed
this situation at all.
If the doctor wants
to see whether
there is an optic and
regulatory cells,
they would still do the same TW.
>> So, basically, it's
not exactly correct.
So, even if you have two,
you can see if there's
a strong regression
with a condition
after MELD that you
couldn't move on.
>> [inaudible].
>> So, imagine computing p-value
[inaudible] distribution
of some gene is different.
Like in this condition versus
condition B you'll do
some statistical tests.
But, I'm saying you can do some
stronger inference on
the meld dimension.
You can compute the correlation
with the condition.
>> Four over A and C? You could
if you're to get
the original data, right?
As you can see the P and
you will not get
the original data.
>> Yeah.
>> Can we do that
[inaudible] again?
So, what about the data
that you see in panel B,
would lead you to conclude that.
>> So, you should
understand that each sound waves
are very heterogeneous spread.
So, there are some.
So, let's maybe go in reverse.
This is the ground truth, okay?
This is the original system.
Now, you measure that
into samples, right?
So, you cut it into one sampling
and one sample here.
The result will be
this MELD, right?
But, there will be some cells
here and some cells
here that we're actually
here at the peak.
But, you're missing
that information out,
or would not, we
can recover that.
>> You're using
similar other genes
around configure it that.
>> Yeah.
>> Which ones are closer
to one and two
versus further away.
>> Exactly.
>> Every genes are changing also?
>> Yes.
>> You learn the manifold
energy expression and
now you use a mouthful to infuse,
to interpolate
these external data.
>> You know why [inaudible].
>> How do you
compute the p-value?
>> We are not
simply focus on p-values.
We don't believe in that.
Any single-cell data it's
actually been shown you can
have any p-value show
anything because
everything is rare.
Because you have
thousands of cells and
20,000 genes, anything
is significant.
>> How do you do
this visualization
tool where they looked
at this and say,
well maybe this is
happening so we shall have
more samples in between.
>> Yeah. You can
see if you think.
>> This is enough for
me to be convinced
that this is what's going
on rather than really.
>> I don't know it's
up to definition.
>> Well. So, one thing
you can to do
is you originally
measure two conditions.
You do MELD and now you
gave these into three bins.
Now, you have three conditions
and now you can do
the same things that you could.
>> So, that we validated
it by doing that.
We've left out
a time point that was
actually measured and we've
melded on the two
time points that are
flanking it and we can
impute back the MELD line.
>> Right.
>> So, we've done validation.
>> But, we're not super
big on statistics
because we realized
[inaudible] statistics.
>> You can, doctors are.
>> Well, they shouldn't be.
>> You could do
a generation null distribution
where you randomize things
and then you could get p-values.
>> But, it's very easy to
get good p-values that way,
so I highly worry about that.
>> Yeah. So, if you do MELD
on a random meta folks,
for example, by the random graph.
>> So, another project that we
did that uses the same ideas is,
we realized that we have of
this high-dimensional
structure but we don't
have a very good way of
visualizing this structure
for exploratory purposes.
So, we, in some cases,
when new genes we
were interested in,
so we're visualizing
biaxial plots.
In other case, we visualize PCA.
But it came to
our attention that all of
these methods leave out
a lot from the data.
So, because we learned
the whole manifold of the data,
there should be
some way of visualizing
it that preserved
structure a bit more.
This led to a project
called PHATE.
That's under revision now.
So, the idea of PHATE is that
because we have
a natural understanding
of the shape of the data,
we can squeeze it into lower
dimensions in such a way
that captures both local and
global structure,
and therefore trajectory
structures in biology,
but also disparates
cluster structures.
We realize that not a lot of
other visualization methods
really preserved
structure in this way.
So, I'm going to show this
both on artificial data
and data generated from
an embryoid body
differentiation system,
where you start out with human
embryonic stem cells and then you
differentiate them
into variety of
different lineages over
a 30-day time course.
So, this artificial tree data,
which my lab sometimes
calls the dump tree,
but you will find out
the dump tree is harder than
it looks as you see here.
So, if you take this dump tree
and you add noise to it,
and you rotate in high
dimensions and you look to
see if you can visualize it.
If you try to
visualize it with PCA,
you're missing a lot
of the structure
in the dump tree even
though it picked up
the global directionality
in some way.
It is going from blue to green,
but it's losing a lot of
the branching structure.
tSNE seems to be
all the range in this field.
I'm not sure, maybe
in other fields too.
But tSNE, actually,
shatters the data
in a bad way because
it only cares
about keeping stochastic
neighbors together.
We believe that if you
don't keep just neighbors
but keep manifold intrinsic
relationships altogether,
that's a better way of
preserving the structure
in the data.
You see, PHATE can preserve
the data but it can also
denoise it, which is important.
So, you see the lines that
PHATE gives are thinner
and also denoise it in the
manifold intrinsic dimensions.
So, here's PHATE shown on.
We especially hope that
a lot of people start
using this because
this is basically can work
on any any type of data.
Here, you see the embryonic
stem cell differentiation system.
The red to the left is
all embryonic stem cells
because that's from
day zero to three,
and we started with
embryonic stem cells.
As the days go on,
you create the lineages
that are colored in
orange that we picked up
on day six through nine.
Then, finally, the blue
or the latest that we
generated 24 through 27.
Again, you see PCA picks up
at least this time label.
The fact that
there's fewer cells,
so there's less space
occupied by the red than
the green and blue because
it's branching out as lineages.
But the internal structure
is not clarified.
The tSNE doesn't even do that.
So, this is very bad for
preserving continuum structure.
So, you see the red is shattered
out on either sides of the
green and the global
relationships
are all completely messed up.
So, can I trust this
for understanding really
the overall global
structure of your data?
Diffusion maps which is
somewhat based on this,
is based on this concept
but it's an older method.
It doesn't preserve in a way
that you can visualize.
Basically, what it's doing
is it's taking each branch,
each trajectory, each
cluster and putting it out
to a different dimension,
so you need to visualize,
you need to look at
many diffusion dimensions to
get at this even though it
has some of this information.
This is how the PHATE
algorithm works.
So, the first three
steps are similar
to the steps that you saw before,
which is, you have the data,
you learn distances
and affinities,
and you power the matrix,
although usually to
a higher power because
you're visualizing in
two or three dimensions.
But, then, we use
some information theoretic
techniques after that.
So, after that, we
realized that we want to
really preserve the
information in this matrix,
information theoretically as much
as possible in low dimensions.
So, we come up with an
information theoretic distance
between these diffusion
probabilities.
Then, again, we don't want
to lose any information,
so instead of just visualizing
eigenvector one versus
eigenvector two,
which is what people do in PCA,
we squeeze all the variability in
add it to dimensions by running
metric MDS on
these informational distances
that we came up with.
So, we're making sure
that we don't leave
any information out
there that we haven't
captured and that we're
capturing as much as
possible in our distances.
The idea of using an
information theoretic distance
is that each point is
a probability distribution,
each point is
a distribution between
affinities or
probabilities of walking.
If you just took this
straight pointwise distance,
it would be dominated by
what's happening with
the nearest neighbors
and it would
look a lot more like tSNE.
But if you use an information
theoretic distance,
usually information
theoretic distances
have a damping factor.
So, you have a log as you
do in Shannon entropy.
So, there's damping factor makes
the low-probability differences
for changes also picked
up by the distance.
The idea, again, of using
metric MDS instead of
Eigendecomposition
is that we only get
two or three or however
many dimensions you want.
It's doing the best job
it can to preserve
all this information
in low dimensions.
So, that gives you PHATE.
Here, again, these are
ground-truth examples,
where we generated the stuff
that's on the first column.
We generated this and
we see what PHATE is
giving us versus what
other things are giving us.
So, sometimes the
other methods do pretty well
on turitive like
the Gaussian mixture model.
Sometimes they again, do weirdly,
like tSNE is putting the
green and red in between
the blue and orangeish color.
Sometimes they are very noisy,
like isomap can be
very noisy because
it's doing geodesic distances,
shortest path distances.
Shortest path distance will take
every shortcut they can throw
every outlier they can.
You can see things like
force-directed layout that
are just trying to
split things out.
Then you get what?
One of my students called
sneeze spots from it,
it looks like a little point
is sneezed out.
There's other methods
called Monocle
that fit trees to data.
It's not quite appropriate
but some reviewers asked us
to compare against that.
Then, you can
imagine that it does
the same thing to
biological data.
So, there's different types
of data we visualize here.
The first is our embryonic
stem cell differentiation data.
The second is
retinal bipolar data,
which they mainly thought
had a lot of clusters
but we can see that the clusters
have some progression
within them.
Then, there's
hematopoietic stem cell
differentiation data in A.
There's IPSE reprogramming in
E. When they're grayed out,
it means those methods
don't scale,
so we had to sample
them to begin with,
which turns out to be a huge
problem for most of these,
where there is kind of
diffusion process can be
made really fast
using some tricks.
So, this is a visualization
of what PHATE was trying to do.
It's trying to keep
global structure like PCA.
There is also clarifying
local structure
because they can denoise
a non-linear
interactions and find
non-linear frictions
of dimensionalities,
so you get more fine grained
detail than you would.
You can zoom in on
those fine details and
I have a zoom-in slide.
But, we can show, for example,
that this orange branch that
the way it's splitting
is actually real and
there's some biological
conclusions about what
the differences between those
two retinal cell types are.
So, what can we do
after we run a PHATE?
You can do a lot of
different things.
You can cluster around
the PHATE dimensions.
We compute intrinsic
dimensionality
to find branching points.
If you have a lot of 1D
trajectories in your data,
branching points have
higher dimension locally,
we can use these branching
points in conjunction with
the clusters to come up with
lineages or regions of analysis.
So, we gave this analysis
to our collaborator at
the Yale Stem Cell Center.
She was able to
play with this tool
and identify a lot of
different lineages.
So, she came up with
this tree of lineages.
There are several intermediates
here that she did not know.
So, this is truly a tool for
people to visualize
their own data from
their own domain and
figure out what's
in the data and use it
for further analysis.
So, we were able to sort out
some of the populations
that she was interested
in and then you can
in fact sort them
and figure out what
to do with it next.
So, the final project
that I'll talk about,
it ties all of
these things together.
>> Can I ask
one question about this?
>> Yes.
>> So, it seems like
there are two big things.
One is using the divisions
to do this moving,
another one is, you replace.
>> To do, yes, go ahead.
>> Then, the other one is
you use this information of
divergence towards the data than
you believe in. I
was just saying.
>> It's okay.
>> So, I'm wondering whether,
have you guys tried to apply
the two aspect and see which one?
>> Yes. So, actually, all
these steps are essential,
there isn't random collection.
Each of these steps is essential
for getting the end results.
So, if you remove
the fusion, it doesn't work.
If you remove the information,
this thing doesn't work.
So, all of these are
essential steps.
>> We've validated
that every step
is basically necessary.
Would we still have
that figure in America paper?
Now, there's always these
constraints when you submit.
>> I'm just wondering
because people use this need
for gene expression
clustering, and there,
I can see the one big
difference is that
the chest group count
is noise to noise as
this thing, right?
>> No, it is. It can be.
So, I think that
these needs may be
okay for some kind of clustering
because it keeps
local neighbors together,
but if your data doesn't
have that kind of
clustering structure
and it keeps them
together at a very
particular granularity.
The granularity is determined
by the perplexity
you set in Teasne.
So, basically, at
that level of granularity,
it's splitting your data
onto clusters,
and I think that's
an okay use-case for Teasne.
But this is not an okay in
this case if you're trying to
find the relationships
between your populations,
which clusters are actually
close to each other,
because also the KL divergence
penalty is very lopsided.
It cares if you put
close neighbors far,
but there's no effective
penalty for putting
far things closer in
any configuration.
But what Teasne does that
PCA doesn't do, for example,
is it does squeeze variability
into two dimensions,
but it does it with
stochastic gradient descent.
So, that's a little random.
So, if you run Teasne many times,
you'll get different results.
So, the next project
I'll talk about is,
so I've talked a lot
about how really
understanding the
shape of the manifold
helps you visualize,
helps you figure
out the differences
between experimental conditions,
it helps you restore transcripts.
So, can we do some of
this with Deep Learning,
which adds to it
all the other features
that deep learning has,
which has even increased
scalability and the ability
to do many things at
the same time because you have
some deep model through which
you can process your data.
>> By the way,
Fade is very scalable.
>> Fade and Magic are
both very scalable,
and David worked a lot on
making them superscalable,
so I'm sure he wants
me to mention that.
But I'm sure you guys know
that in deep learning,
you can form it out to
a bunch of GPUs or something.
The more GPUs you have
to parallelize this,
but if you have a lot
of CPUs, it's fine.
So, SAUCIE is an auto-encoder
based framework,
and that's what the A stands for,
so we think really hard
about making these acronyms.
So, the idea of
SAUCIE is actually to
find these kind of
patterns emergently
in a neural network,
instead of using
some kind of diffusion
based algorithms based on
constraints and regularizations.
What we're trying to
do with SAUCIE is,
we're trying to go to the realm
where there's
massive amounts of data.
Jonathan was saying
today that there's
massive amounts of
TCR data, for example.
So, if we have
massive amounts of data,
like single-cell data
collected on many,
many samples, we want to be able
to run it through
the system, and come out,
and read a lot of
patterns of the fact that
an Auto-encoder
Neural Network is essentially
a non-linear dimensionality
reduction as
long as you have
non-linear activations.
So, some of the things that
we designed SAUCIE to do are,
from the ways that different
layers are regularized,
we can read these patterns
off the data.
So, actually, people
always complain
that you don't know
what the inside of
a neural network is doing,
and that's not true
in our case of
our neural network
because the outside,
it's doing one interesting thing,
which is de-noising data,
but other than that, it's just
recreating it's own input.
That's what an auto-encoder does.
The internal layers are
good for visualization.
We can read clusters
off one of the layers.
We can batch align or
batch normalize them.
Then, we can also
recreate the output.
So, those are
the different layers.
Then finally, it gives
you the non-linear
dimensionality reduction.
On particular patients,
it can give you
stratifications of
the patients themselves.
So, I guess you
don't need an explanation
of deep neural networks.
An auto-encoder was first
introduced many years ago.
I don't know when it
was first introduced.
It was popularized in
the science paper in 2006,
and the idea is very simple
that the only penalty that
the neural network
natively enforces
is that the input be
recreated as the output,
and so this makes
it unsupervised.
You don't need any labels.
It means that if you
have reduced dimensions
in the middle of that,
they have some kind of
dimensionality reduction going on.
So, this is more specifically
what SAUCIE looks like.
So, SAUCIE has an MMD penalty
or a penalty to align batches,
enforced on it's
lowest dimensional layer.
The idea here is that you
treat the batches as
different distributions
and align them.
There's a layer that's
two-dimensional that you
can use for visualization.
There's a layer that has
a special regularization
that we call the Information
Dimension Regularization
that binarizes activations or
makes them easily binarizable.
There, you can read
clusters off the data.
Finally, the output layer
de-noises the data because
it's trying to recreate
the data after throwing off
all these dimensions
in the middle.
>> [inaudible] here,
reconstruction
sits because every based on
the stuff that you
shared earlier,
it seems like that particular
elementary tissues,
they've got a difference
in terms of [inaudible].
>> So, SAUCIE is not
stochastic although we have
other synthetic neural networks.
It is using a simple
reconstruction loss like
Mean Squared Error.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes. But there's
penalty terms due to the
regularizations. So, there's an.
>> In the other variables?
>> Yes, but they're
all added to the, yes.
>> So, for example,
[inaudible] and it looks
like you're actually doing
something different.
Yeah, and I can go over that.
I think I have some slides to
go over how we constrain it.
We constrain it so
that layer is giving us.
>> Most people aren't really
using tights weights anymore.
>> Some people do probably, but.
>> Yeah, but it seems to know
where it is well. [inaudible]
>> People also use
the same network architecture
just flip in [inaudible].
>> Right, right.
That's true, yeah.
But you can have, you can
constrain through the rest.
>> Actually, also, I don't
think that layer size
is similar as is shown here.
I think it's this thinner
layer, it's sparse.
So, visualization, again, you can
compare to these other
methods like PCA,
tSNE and things like that.
You just take the two-dimensional
layer and visualize it.
This the representation for
the clustering to
the idea was this,
if you have some
cluster of cells,
you want to be able to read
off which cluster they're in.
Then, within cluster variation,
is only stored in
a small range on top
of this binarization.
It's still there because
it recreates it,
but the majority
of the signal that
these nodes are giving is
which cluster it's in.
So, this particular cluster
is encoded by basically 011,
and a different cluster
could be encoded by
something different.
So, the way you do this is,
we penalize for
activation entropy
as von Neumann Entropy.
If you take all of your
activation values,
and you treat them as
a probability distribution,
and you compute
Shannon Entropy on it,
if all your nodes are
activated to
roughly the same level,
then you'll have high
von Neumann Entropy if
you can call it that.
If one of them is one,
and a lot of them are zeros
or a few of them are ones
and a lot of them are zeros,
and you have low
activation entropy.
So, this gives you binarizable
entries or activation.
So, with no regularization you
see a lot of things are
activated middle, high.
L1 Regularization, which
a lot of people use
just avoids the very high value,
and then they're pushed over
and you still have
a lot of entropy there.
But our regularization gives
you a binarizable shape.
If you round it or
actually binarize it,
you get cluster
level information rather than
cell level information from this.
That's the main idea of
the regularization on the layer
that reads off the clusters.
For the batch effects,
this is an embedding of patient
one versus patient two,
and this is a Dengue
patient data set.
We use a probabilistic distance.
This been use a little bit
in Neural Network.
It's been there too much just
called Maximal Mean Discrepancy,
and you can compute this
at the batch level.
You're computing the batch one B
have minimal probabilistic
distance to batch two.
But it still has to reconstruct
and do these other things.
So, it encourages to
minimally align the data and
not totally re-scramble it.
So, for the red and the blue
are different patient
so the embedding is mainly
organized by patient,
which we don't want.
We want the batch effects
between when the patients
were measured,
what time of the day
all of that to go away.
So, after MMD, you see that
it's organized by cell type.
So now, we can see how
my CD3 positive cells both
these patients have and things
like that. I don't know.
We tried this on
this Dengue data,
it was from NIMHANS
in Bangalore is
a Neuroradiology
Department in NIMHANS.
So, they gave us.
It's something like 60 patients,
and they visited two times,
and then there's
an additional number
of patients who came with them,
and they are
the healthy controls,
were living in
the same environment.
So, there were 180 files,
each of them have many,
many cells, and so,
totally this data was
20 million cells.
You had to batch normalized
between 180 different files,
and there's the few
batch normalization tools
that are out there don't really
normalize at this scale.
They do two conditions
or something like that.
You see what the cells look
like if you combine
all the acutes,
and there are healthy
versus the convalescent.
Convalescent are acute people
they came back some weeks later,
and their cells are
starting to look a lot
more like the healthy
just to inject.
But you see that there's
no batch effect.
You can see each of
the acute patients
separately or anything like that,
it's a unified manifold.
On this unified manifold,
you can go ahead and cluster
like it's one data set,
which wasn't possible before.
There's other methods that
will cluster totally separately,
and then try to
match these clusters
and turns into
a huge huge problem.
Instead, you can just cluster
this data as if
it's one data set.
You come up with
these populations of cells.
We find that some of
the populations of cells,
for example, are
very interesting.
There's the TC or
Gamma Delta population,
and we saw that a lot in
the acutely infected
patients that they
have NK cells on those.
They have so many activity.
They show signs of
innate activity,
and this is a rare population,
but we can still pick up
a systematic difference.
Then, you can see
these signatures
of these different cell types
for the different patients
that are acute,
convalescent or healthy,
and then you could embed it
again with an MMD-based,
DMD-based distance.
We see that all the patients
themselves are
stratified where the left side
of the embedding is a lot of
the acute patients and
the right side is convalescent,
and you see people
are convalescing to
different extents and
things like that.
Then you can associate this
with the proportions of
different clusters that you
see in your clustering.
Of course, the point that I was
making is that you're
running all of
this through
these neural networks
that are tricked out or whatever,
so it should be scalable,
and we actually do find
that it's very scalable.
We compare it against K-means
and Phenograph
clustering methods.
tSNE is a clustering,
but also visualization method.
PHATE, this is
the old PHATE sorry,
compared against
the nonsupervised PHATE.
PCA Neural Network, Completion,
MNN is a type of
batch normalization,
diffusion maps, all
of these things,
and it's super, super fast.
Faster than everything besides,
I think it was PCA.
That's because now
PCA is done with
random projection matrix
is really quickly.
The PCA doesn't give
you very good results.
You randomly linearly projecting,
you're losing a lot
of information.
So, quality wise, SAUCIE is
way better than any kind of
PCA because it does
so many other things and
it's a non-linear method.
Finally, it's because I added
one slide because Jonathan
was talking a lot about dynamics.
We have a neural
network that we're
training also to predict
dynamics in these things,
and this network is generative
and it's stochastic,
so we're calling
this the transcoder
and because PHATE and
these other methods allow
us to pick up trajectories,
we're hoping to mimic
these trajectories and find
some deep representation
of the logic that's used
to make these transitions.
But that's an ongoing project.
We're hoping that test
systems, evolution systems
pertain folding systems
and things like that.
Those are the main projects
that I want to talk about.
Again, the main idea is we
pick up a lot of structure
that could otherwise
go missing in data by using
very careful non-linear
dimensionality reduction and
manifold learning
methods using graph
signal processing and
also deep learning.
We believe that these have
wide applicability
much beyond what
I said to the specific data sets
that I was showing it on.
I also have a lot of
talented students
and postdocs in my lab.
So, I try to get them to
intern at IBM right now.
They were doing a hackathon then,
and so, I just took pictures
of them at that hackathon.
Actually, I think
they were having
a lot fun in the clinic.
Of course, we collaborate
with a lot of people
at Yale including immunologists,
infectious disease people,
Stem Cell neurologists,
Yale Center for Genome Analysis.
Others stuff that I've
talked about is on GitHub
but maybe besides transcoder.
Papers on Bioarchive, some of
the papers on related topics
are in nips in ICMO.
A lot of them are in bioarchive
also our regular archive.
You can feel free to email me.
>> This for PHATE and then you
can [inaudible] in Python?
>> Yes.
>> SAUCIE is just
in the [inaudible]
>> Yeah, we notice even though
nobody in my lab likes or uses R,
well, just someone you
say it unless you code
it in R. We make
someone to do it.
So, let me know. Why?
Are you an R fan?
No, okay. What do
you guys code in?
You're on languages?
>> Sure.
>> Why not. Start an argument.
>> What century is this?
>> What centuries is this?
If you have any
questions, let me know.
We have additional slides on it.
You said something?
Yeah. Go ahead.
>>In terms of a scalability gain,
some of it largely like-
>> I'm sorry, what?
>> So, you showed us
the scalability thing, right?
So, think of it as magic and
say you need to think about
this parallelize distance and
that's where you get
the blow up words-.
>> Yeah, that's effectively what
you get. Let me go through that.
>> Yeah, okay. But
why in that case-
>> I do have a slide
that shows that.
>> The supplemental slide deck.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> But also a related
question is that
can you imagine using
a neural network in
a way to do the same thing
when you do the diffusion?
>> We do use a neural network.
We could do the same thing.
>> But right now you
use a diffusion to-.
>> So, you don't get
the neural network like SOS.
It doesn't explicitly.
>> The last layers of
SOS actually give you
the same risk of
reconstructions as magic.
It most closely compares to
MAGIC more so than to
the other imputation methods.
This is actually in
the SOS manuscript.
But this actually shows
that this neural
network also learns
the manifold without
diffusion and
without us having to define
distance and other things.
>> With some other types
of logout filters.
It's just not incredibly
diffusion in the graph but-.
>> We have a very similar thing
where you'll have
a knowledge graph.
Your knowledge graph could be
a relation between the entity.
Then traditional people use
random walkthrough to compute
a diffusion probability.
>> You mean like a word vectors
or something like that?
>> Yeah. Nowadays,
we embed it into
embedding and then you can
compute any arbitrary thing
without doing any random walk.
Because a random walk
would be expensive.
>> Right.
Given that we have-
sorry about that.
>> Yes. So you want to talk
about this slider here.
>> Yeah, nice.
>> This one I think.
>> So, instead of computing
all paths between points,
we're constraining the paths to
go through specific landmarks.
We fix the number of landmarks.
We pick enough of them to
accurately describe the graph.
So now we essentially
get a linear place.
>> So now, the
diffusion goes from
original points to landmark
points to original points.
But if you do the matrix
association correctly.
>> The landmarks are chosen to be
uniformly representing
the whole graph.
So we use very
little information.
But we're still going to exclude
the vast majority of paths.
>> So you literally
random sample them?
>> No.
>> We actually use
a spectral clustering approach.
>> Okay.
>> Using fast random SDD.
So it's all super-fast.
>> I see.
>> So essentially
the whole thing is linear.
>> So it's almost
linear, a little
bit linear random projection?
>> Yeah. We're doing random
projection to big landmarks,
and then we compute paths to
go through our landmarks.
>> That's very intriguing.
>> It works almost exactly with
the same result as the
original search plane version.
>> Okay. You can look
up PHATE done by by
archiver Ron Sells Sneakpeek
and how he show
these comparisons and thousands
of supplemental figures
and something like that.
>> Sp the speck thing
in the runtime there,
is that when you're not
using as many landmarks
as the points or?
>> Exactly. That's
a very good observation.
So, we use I
think by default something
like 2,000 landmarks.
So when you have fewer points
than that number,
there's no point in doing this.
Yeah. So only really large
numbers help to do this.
That's exactly why
we have that photo.
>> The other motivation for
SOS isn't just scalability.
It's also that all these sets
are implemented on
some unified representation
of the data.
So we find that
some clustering methods
they may represent
the data's graph or
some kind of cloud,
and then you have a batch
normalization method
that represents
data as canonical
correlation dimensions.
There's something. There's
very disparate stuff.
The different features
you're reading off the data
are not made from
the same representation
so they're not correlated
to each other.
>> TC in your data,
there's no guarantee that
TC picks up the same
clustered as K-means because they
have different algorithms
representations.
That was one of the reasons
that we wanted to do this.
>> We do stochastic
gradient this side.
You pass the gradient
all the way back so
all the layers are coordinating.
>> Here we have
one representations that
guarantees that you get
the same clusters as
your visualization.
>> So that clustering
where we use
the information entropy to
measure the constraint,
that's going to effectively
push you towards picking
a single cluster at
that layer. Right?
>> You're forcing the nodes
to become binaries or digital.
Either zeros or ones.
>> Even moreso we force
them to be single one-
>> Not a single one.
>> A single one would
be like L1 sparsity.
Sparsity it will just try
to make as many nodes up to zero.
We're not doing that. We want
the nodes to be zeros or ones.
We want them binary or digital.
>> So they're being computed
on each node independently?
>> Each node becomes
a probability and then
we use Shannon entropy.
We use Shannon entropy.
>> I'm calling it a name
entropy because it's like
an entropy of values
rather than probabilities.
That's why I was calling it that.
>> So within each node
or crossover node?
>> Crossover.
>> Per set.
>> Yeah, it's across the nodes.
>> Across the nodes.
>> Yeah. But what we don't
see that it gives us
a single one because it's not
specifically a sparsity penalty.
So, usually the neural network
will not make it one hard.
It'll make it low entropy
given that it can
still reconstruct.
So usually, the
vectors are 3-4-1s.
>> Is it just one
you could put in
the soft nodes where
you're pushing into one.
>> Yeah. One-hot encoding.
You could do that.
>> But we don't usually do that.
We don't push it to one-hot.
>> With one-hot you still have
to pick the number of nodes
which will give you
the number of clusters.
In this case actually we don't-.
>> We don't know the number of
clusters that we are pairing.
>> What I'm saying
here is we don't know
the number of clusters,
so we don't have to define.
We've set the number of
clusters we get out of it.
>> But we can overall tweak
the granularity by upping
this penalty or
downing this penalty.
But we don't know
exactly how many like
when we're saying
10K means give us
10 clustering or something.
>> So how do you set
this coefficient
for the regularization right now?
>> So that's a variable.
It depends on if you
want really big clusters
like T-cells versus
B-cells versus monocytes.
Or if you want to go inside
the T-cells and see
the different sub textures.
>> Also that's pretty robust.
We see that we change
its biologies
pretty similar or whatever
test cases we have.
Gaussian mixtures or whatever.
So it's pretty robust
against those preferences.
Cool. Well, thank you guys.
>> Thank you.